me di cuenta que en el vídeo pasado yo
cometió un pequeño error al hablarles de
la media poblacional y la media muestral
entonces más vale repasarlo de una vez y
corregir ese error para que ustedes
entiendan en qué consistía ese pequeño
error entonces yo había definido a la
media poblacional con la letra griega mu
y ésta era igual a la suma de todos los
datos de mi población es decir a todos
los x y y aquí fue donde cometí el error
es la vez pasada posee x n y no es xy
todos los datos de mi población desde y
igual a uno hasta n mayúscula hasta n
mayúscula que son todos los datos que
tengo toda la cantidad de datos que
tengo y todo esto entre la cantidad de
datos que tengo es decir todo esto sobre
n y esto es igual a x 1 + x2 x 3 + todos
estos hasta x n mayúscula y dividido
entre n
recuerden que estoy tomando todo
los datos de mi población y así definía
yo a la media poblacional ahora bien si
yo quiero hablar de la media muestral es
decir no de toda la población solamente
de un subgrupo de la población las de
notó con una equis con una barra encima
x con un sombrerito encima y esto es
igual a la suma de todas las equis y que
están en mi subgrupo poblacional y voy a
tomar la suma de todas ellas es decir
desde igual a uno hasta n minúscula aquí
radica la diferencia entre mi media
muestral y mi media poblacional porque
uno tiene una n minúscula y la otra
tiene una n mayúscula en mayúscula habla
de todos los datos de mi población en
minúscula habla de los datos que tengo
en mi subgrupo a la cual estoy
calculando la media muestral
y todo esto dividido entre en es decir
x1 + x2 más valor bla
+ x subíndice n minúscula entre n aquí
están las dos diferencias entre la media
muestral y la media poblacional
y bueno esencialmente parecen ser lo
mismo pero no lo son uno habla de toda
la población y otro habla de un espacio
más pequeño es decir de un subgrupo de
la población pero bueno todo esto nos va
a llevar a hablar sobre medidas de
dispersión de hecho lo que habíamos
visto en el primer lista de vídeos
acerca de estadística era sacar la media
la moda la mediana y todo eso era ni más
ni menos que medir la tendencia central
de un grupo de datos es decir escoger un
número que sea el más representativo de
todos los números sin embargo se pierde
mucha información pero qué pasa si nos
queremos fijar en la media y saber qué
tan lejos estamos de la media a bueno
para eso estamos medidas de dispersión
entonces vamos a hacer lo siguiente en
este vídeo vamos a analizar medidas de
dispersión supongamos que tenemos un
caso particular primero voy a hablar de
que tenemos los números 2 2 3 y 3 si
tengo esta población cuál es la media de
esta población pues es muy fácil
calcularlo tenemos que sumar todo y
dividirlo entre la cantidad de datos
22 33 y dividirlo entre 4 porque son
cuatro datos y esto me queda pues dos
más dos son cuatro tres más tres que es
seis entonces son diez entre cuatro y
estos 2.5 muy bien ahora qué pasa si yo
me tomo otra población son poblaciones
distintas y esta población tiene los los
valores los datos de 0 0 5 y 5 si yo
saco la media a esta nueva población y
ojo con mucho cuidado estas dos
poblaciones son distintas una es la
primera población y la otra es la
segunda población pues la media va a ser
la suma de los cuatro dígitos es 0 +0 5
500 más 5 + 5 / otra vez entre 4 porque
son 4 datos y esto pues es lo mismo es
2.5 es decir tenemos dos conjuntos de
datos dos poblaciones distintas que
ambas tienen como media a 2.5 sin
embargo en el primer grupo
de datos la media que es la tendencia
central está más cerca de los datos que
yo tengo mientras que en el otro la
media o la tendencia central está mucho
más alejada de los datos de mi población
es decir en el primer conjunto de datos
2.5 que es la media está muy cerca de
dos y de tres y en el segundo grupo 2.5
que es mi media está dos en unidades y
media lejos de cero y dos unidades y
medias lejos de cinco es decir la
distancia que hay de la media a uno de
mis datos es mucho más grande que la
distancia que hay de mi media a uno de
los datos en mi primer grupo bueno pues
para saber qué tan lejos o no está mi
media o dicho de otra manera que tan
representativa es mi tendencia central
se usa la varianza y la varianza que se
denota con una letra sigma bueno aquí me
quedo muy grande la parte de arriba y no
quiero correr el riesgo de que toda la
vida hagan la sigma con muy grande de la
parte de arriba
ahora sí sigma cuadrada es la varianza y
porque sigma cuadrada y no p chica de
varianza pues bueno eso lo voy a
explicar con más detalle más adelante no
comandancias la varianza se define como
sigma cuadrada y es igual a quien bueno
primero tomamos una suma tiene lógica
tomar una suma porque lo que vamos a
medir es qué tan lejos estamos o no de
la media entonces es la suma desde igual
a uno hasta n otra vez estamos tomando
lo mismo de quien a pues lo que quiero
yo medir es qué tan lejos estoy del
promedio o no es decir x y ya está xy le
voy a quitar la media o estoy hablando
de la media pues entonces tengo que
quitar la media para saber qué tan lejos
o no estoy de mi media y a esto lo voy a
elevar al cuadrado y porque está elevado
al cuadrado bueno si se dan cuenta lo
que tenemos aquí es la distancia entre
el punto xy
la media y al elevarlo al cuadrado
hacemos una cosa muy importante que es
volverlo positivo y bueno todo esto hay
que dividirlo entre la cantidad de datos
que tenemos y así definimos a la
varianza y bueno justo ahora se van a
dar cuenta de lo que les estoy tratando
de decir y de explicar en este momento
así que me voy a tomar otra vez el
primer conjunto de números tenía el 22
33 mejor lo voy a escribir de esta
manera creo que si lo escribo de esta
manera va a ser mucho más fácil que
veamos a donde quiero llegar entonces
voy a hacer una tabla y aquí voy a poner
a i y es 1234 porque tenemos 4 datos y
quién es x y bueno x y lo importante es
que pongamos x 1 x 2 x 3 x 4 pero no
importa quién tomemos como x 1 como x 2
como x 3 y como x 4 porque al final los
vamos a sumar todos y los vamos a
dividir entre n entonces recuerden que
el orden de los sumandos no afecta la
suma entonces los voy a tomar así tal
cual como están x1 es igual a 2 x 2 va a
ser igual también a 2
x 3 va a ser igual a 3 que voy a dejar
de escribir x team y x 4 va a ser igual
a 3 ok ahora quien leerá la media la
media es igual para todos los datos es
2.5 y ya habíamos calculado entonces la
media de 2.5 2.5 2.5 2.5 ahora si lo que
me voy a tomar en el siguiente en la
siguiente parte de mi tabla es la
distancia que hay del punto xy a la
media es decir la resta de xy menos la
media y esto es igual a 2 menos 2.5 es
menos punto 52 menos 2.5 otra vez es
menos punto 53 menos 2.5 es punto 5
positivo y 3.5 puntos 5 positivo y bueno
después la fórmula nos pide sacar x y
menos me elevado al cuadrado y
esencialmente lo estamos elevando al
cuadrado porque queremos tener
cantidades positivas porque si
tuviéramos cantidades negativas
estaríamos restando cuál es la
diferencia entre elevarlo al cuadrado y
tomar el valor absoluto ya lo
platicaremos más
ahorita vamos a elevar del cuadrado
primero y menos punto 5 al cuadrado es
punto 25 positivo menos punto 5 al
cuadra 2.25 positivo punto 5 al cuadrado
2.25 y punto 5 al cuadrado 2.25 ok
entonces ya tengo yo la parte de arriba
o sea el denominador de mi varianza que
es la suma desde igualdad 1 hasta 4 de x
menos vivo elevado al cuadrado es decir
punto 25 más puntos 25 más 125 más
puntos 25 que es 1 si multiplicamos
punto 25 por 4 es lo mismo que 1 y ahora
si la varianza va a ser todo eso que
acabamos de calcular dividido entre n es
decir entre la cantidad de datos que yo
tengo entonces sigma cuadrada o la
varianza es igual a 1 sobre la cantidad
de datos que es 4 o dicho de otra manera
estos puntos 25 es decir el promedio o
la media que hay de cada uno de nuestros
datos a la media del conjunto de la
población es lo mismo que uno entre 4 o
sea punto 25
pero esto era para el primer grupo de
datos que teníamos para la primera
población qué va a pasar o cómo va a
cambiar si yo lo cálculo para la segunda
población la varianza va a ser la misma
pues veamos me voy a tomar a mi segunda
población y para no reescribir todo
solamente voy a hacer una pequeña tabla
que tengan que ver con xy y con la
diferencia entonces aquí voy a tomarme a
x y que en este caso son 0 0 5 y 5 y
aquí xy menos la media
entonces xy es 0 0 5 y 5 y bueno la
media era 2.5 entonces lo que quiero
calcular ahora este es x 1 este es x 2
este es x 3 y 3 x 4 y la diferencia es
lo que la distancia que hay de la media
a cada uno de mis puntos 0 punto menos
2.5 es menos 2.50 menos 2.5 es menos 2.5
52.5 es 2.5 y 5 menos 2.5 también es 2.5
muy bien y si ahora nos llevamos al
cuadrado me queda menos 2.5 l
al cuadrado que es 6.25 menos 2.5
elevado al cuadrado también en 6.25 y de
misma manera es 6.25 y 6.25 cuando tengo
el caso de 2.5 muy bien y si ahora sumo
todo esto y lo divido entre la cantidad
de datos pues me queda 6.25 por 4
dividido entre 4 que es 6.25 por lo
tanto ya es muy fácil saber quién es la
varianza en este caso la varianza es
6.25 por lo tanto ya tenemos dos grupos
de datos los cuales tenían la misma
media y sin embargo tienen la varianza
distinta en el primer caso la varianza
edad punto 25 y en el segundo caso la
varianza era 6.25 qué quiere decir esto
bueno al menos lo que tenemos de
intuición es que en el primer caso como
entendemos una varianza más pequeña esto
nos está diciendo que nuestros puntos
con nuestros datos están más cerca de la
media es decir la tendencia central está
más cerca de mis puntos mientras que en
el segundo caso se nota porque la
varianza es mucho mayor que mis puntos
están más
y bueno esto es lo que tenemos que ver
en este vídeo ya se me está acabando el
tiempo por lo tanto en el siguiente
vídeo voy a hablar con más calma acerca
de la varianza y también vamos a
introducir el concepto de desviación
típica así que no se pierdan el
siguiente vídeo